ahora de la información económica aquí
en directo américa por ello ya está en
el estudio mi compañera daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida hoy vamos a empezar
hablando del g7 esta reunión que están
sosteniendo que apunta con nuevas
sanciones a un ingreso clave del kremlin
y valentina muy buenas noches pues de
haber después de haber sancionado
fuertemente el petróleo ruso occidente
tiene un nuevo objetivo y este es el oro
este commodity es el segundo renglón de
exportación ruso y este martes el grupo
conformado por japón reino unido canadá
eeuu francia italia y alemania acordó
prohibir sus importaciones como parte
del más reciente paquete de sanciones
ahora veamos que tan importante es este
es un golpe que podría ser muy duro si
se tiene en cuenta que según la casa
blanca estos siete países le compran el
90 por ciento del oro a rusia por unos
19 mil millones de dólares al año y los
ingresos por exportaciones son los que
están precisamente manteniendo al país
en pie desde que se intensificaron las
sanciones por la invasión a ucrania se
estima entonces que rusia tiene reservas
por 100 mil y 140 mil millones de
dólares y comparte con australia el
segundo puesto como mayores productores
del mundo después de china bueno estará
una propuesta a eeuu y del reino unido
pero ya se aprobó es decir ya probaron
que no van a importar más fuero ruso o
faltan procesos procedimientos lo ha
probado eeuu el reino unido también
tiene libertad para hacerlo pero países
como italia alemania y francia no pueden
hacerlo todavía porque tienen que ser
tiene que ser una decisión en conjunto
con los 27 países de la unión europea ok
estaremos entonces muy pendientes de
esta decisión cambiamos de tema y vamos
a ser y lanka porque la economía se
contrajo en el primer trimestre lo hizo
valentina en un 16 por ciento en
comparación con el mismo período del año
pasado pero se espera que se contraiga
desde luego todavía más en el segundo
precio nada esta economía por la
inflación la devaluación de la moneda y
también las bajas reservas de divisas y
es que esta nación de 22 millones de
habitantes está apenas días de quedarse
sin combustible también tiene escasez de
otros bienes básicos como alimentos o
medicinas
el gobierno cerró escuelas y
temporalmente también limitó el
suministro de combustible exclusivamente
para los servicios esenciales como lo
son la salud los trenes y los autobuses
suena una situación bastante crítica
daniela venimos ahora a américa latina
porque en argentina hay protestas y
fuertes protestas por el precio de los
combustibles claro y es que imágenes de
drones mostraron filas de camiones
bloqueando la vía de entrada a la
capital buenos aires en una protesta que
ya completa seis días por la escasez y
el aumento de los precios del
combustible diésel específicamente este
mes el gobierno elevó el contenido de
biodiesel requerido en las mezclas de
diésel con la esperanza de que pudiera
ayudar a aliviar estas clases para los
motores industriales sin embargo según
el sindicato nacional de transporte de
carga 21 de las 23 provincias no tienen
suficiente gasolina
nosotros les pedimos al gobierno que nos
atienda que queremos charlar yo no sé si
tienen todas las soluciones pero no va a
haber nunca una solución sino una charla
sabemos que hay camiones que están
viendo en el interior que lo retiren así
no nos dejan participar no nos dejan
llegar y nosotros lo único que pedimos
llegar no estamos pidiendo otra cosa
queremos manifestarnos en un acto
programado por un accidente de la brida
que somos parte de esa central obvia es
que es crítica la situación que está
viviendo argentina daniela vamos ahora a
londres porque lázaro las autoridades
frenaron las intenciones del aeropuerto
de subir sus tarifas les salió un poco
al revés diseñar a ver esta historia que
tan interesante de valentina el
aeropuerto heathrow quería duplicar la
tarifa de aterrizaje que cobra a las
aerolíneas y decían que era para brindar
un mejor servicio a los usuarios sin
embargo este plan provocó la furia de
aerolíneas como british airways y virgin
atlantic que argumentaron que éste ya
está dentro de los aeropuertos más caros
del mundo la autoridad de aviación civil
de gran bretaña tuvo que intervenir y en
lugar de permitir que duplicarán este
costo lo que hicieron fue ordenar que
las tarifas promedio bajen en un período
de cuatro años en aproximadamente un 13%
los voceros de registro respondieron que
los usuarios se van a tener que someter
entonces a una mala experiencia ya que
no va a haber dinero para invertir en el
mejoramiento del servicio bueno vamos
con los indicadores económicos de esta
jornada la bolsa de nueva york que se
cerró con pérdidas después de que se
conocieran malos datos de confianza del
consumidor que empañaron todavía las
pocas expectativas que le quedan a los
inversionistas sobre la recuperación de
la economía en europa por el contrario
las acciones subieron esto después de
que china relajará sus medidas de
cuarentena por kobe de 19 en américa
latina vemos como la bolsa de méxico
encadenó tres sesiones al alza y la de
argentina subió casi un 3% daniela y
vamos a cerrar con la cifra del día nos
quedamos en américa latina porque en 33
por ciento se ubicó la tasa de desempleo
en méxico en mayo es inferior al 4% del
año pasado y una de las más bajas del
continente se estima que en esa nación
hay 1,9 millones de pesos sin trabajo
pero la mala noticia es que seis de cada
diez empleados son informales es decir
32 millones de personas mal que afecta a
américa latina en actualmente daniela a
usted muchas gracias por esta
información económica ya continuamos
aquí en directo américa con directo